Film Courage: Have you seen people who have
supposedly “made it” (and we won’t mention
any names) but they feel like they haven’t
made it and that really with making it you
never really assume that you’ve made it
[or arrived].
That it’s one job to the next, dry spells,
failures, a success.
That there’s not…”Oh yes, this is textbook
making it.”
Jack Perez, Filmmaker: That’s a great question.
I don’t know about other people but I know
it in myself.
I definitely know it in myself that I’m
still thinking about making it.
I don’t know about other people because
I haven’t really spoken to…I have friends
of mine who are classically big success filmmakers
but I’ve never heard them talk about that
they don’t think they’ve made it.
Maybe they have.
I mean I think if you’re ambitious and you’re
shooting for something maybe you never really
see what you have attained.
And I think that for someone like myself I
know that there have been plenty of times
recently where I’ve been like jealous of
someone else’s success or feeling like I
got screwed and didn’t get to make enough
movies or get the kind of budgets I think
I deserved or things like that.
And it really takes somebody on the outside
like my wife going you know what you are whining
about poor me but think about how many people
would like have given up their arms to have
done what you did.
Sometimes it takes that kind of bucket of
cold water to go yeah yeah yeah you are right.
I am the luckiest guy on earth.
I think that the ambitious person they are
already looking for the next thing anyway
so if you are satisfied with what you’ve
done maybe you’re not going to do the next
thing anyway and you just go “Well I did
it.”
But the thing that I think drives creative
people is this need to keep doing it.
In a way you keep kind of canceling out, you
are forgetting what you did.
But it’s not enough anyway.
I think about this sometimes because we spend
all this time gearing up and thinking about
it and finally making the thing and then that’s
going to be over and then shortly after that
you’re kind of like “I’m not happy.
I’ve got to do another thing.”
I remember seeing in that great documentary
IT CAME FROM KUCHAR about George and Mike
Kuchar.
And the great experimental independent filmmaker
George Kuchar is making some crazy project
and they are filming him putting the last
touches on the editing.
He makes the last cut and as soon as he makes
the last cut he goes “Now I’m depressed.
I’ve got to make another movie.”
It’s almost that immediate, back to the
addict thing, you need that thing.
So I think that attributes to a lack of perspective
which I know I’ve had where I’m just so
concentrated on what I need to do next to
fulfill whatever it is that I’ve forgotten
that I’ve done some things that I should
be happy with.
Like yes, you managed to accomplish that’s
good.
Maybe that’s more typical that not, I don’t
know?
Film Courage: Maybe in some ways that’s
a good quality to have - forgetting about
your success a day after it happens because
then it’s going to keep you going to the
next, going to the next.
Jack: I think so.
Film Courage: Because if you are too happy
about it, that’s it.
I don’t need it.
Jack: Yes, I think it can be a nice balance.
I think that in the time where you are not
getting…when things are falling apart.
Like even if you’ve only made one movie
or short and you are struggling to make the
next thing and you feel like it’s never
going to happen you should still be able to
hopefully call upon what you have done, even
if it’s just written the screenplay you
can say “You know what?
I accomplished that.
It was not easy.”
No everybody can do that, that’s something
to feel good about while I worry about that
I worry about that I’m not making the next
thing.
If you can take that information and use that
to support yourself and take care of yourself
I think that’s a healthy thing to remember
as opposed to just being in a constant state
of want or a constant state of I don’t have
and I must…like a junkie again waiting to
get well.
It’s like in a way you almost need to remember
what you have accomplished and use that as
a buoy or something to lift yourself up when
you do have those dry spells which are frequent.
Most of us never get to make a movie every
year or every two years or even every three
years.
It takes a lot of time and you have to have
something to sustain yourself other than misery
that you are just not making a movie.
It’s a good question.
It makes me think about it.
I’ve got to stop whining sometimes.